[Musique]
on est le collectif zip et aujourd'hui
on fait cette activation à l'événement
échappé verte c'est un collectif qu'on a
monté spécialement parce qu'on est
L'Oréal on a été lauréat en 2023 de
l'appel à projet partage ton Grand Paris
nous on est répondu avec cette
installation qui a pour but d'être une
cuisine itinérante qui va se greffer sur
des événements ou créer ses propres
événements sur le plateau de Paris
Saclay durant la fin d'année 2023 donc
on a un groupe d'architectes architectes
d'intérieur on s'est rencontré à la fois
pendant nos études mais aussi en dehors
et on s'est structuré cette année pour
la réponse à cet appel à projet
le projet c'est la conception et la
construction de cette cuisine est
inhérente donc qui a été fabriqué juste
avant l'événement les installations dans
les événements elles ont pour but de
parler de l'alimentaire local sur le
plateau et c'est un projet à une échelle
d'architecture donc une installation un
petit pavillon mais qui du fait qu'il
soit itinérant à une visée un peu plus
large une visée un peu plus territoriale
nous ce qu'on cherche à transmettre avec
cette cuisine c'est cette valoriser un
peu la cuisine déjà pour que les gens
s'intéressent à cuisiner eux-mêmes faire
les choses avec des produits locaux des
produits de saison et si possible
d'utiliser des déchets ou des choses qui
sont un peu moins valorisés de
l'habitude l'exemple qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on cuisine avec des fans de
carottes donc qui sont les déchets
normalement qui partent à la poubelle et
là on essaie de les transformer autre
chose donc on a fait des salades et on a
fait des pesto c'est des choses que
chacun peut faire assez facilement c'est
de montrer à tout le monde que la
cuisine c'est facile c'est rapide
et que c'est accessible à tout le monde
tous les produits qu'on a utilisés
aujourd'hui c'est des produits qui sont
issus de d'agriculteurs du coin au
maximum quoi essayer de en fonction des
saisons
par la construction de ce pavillon nous
ce qui nous intéressait en tant que en
tant qu'architecte c'est de
d'évoquer les problématiques auxquelles
nous vous en face en ce début de 21ème
siècle et notamment le problème que nous
avons vis-à-vis des ressources et c'est
pour ça qu'on a choisi de construire non
pas intégralement notre pavillon en
matériaux de réemploi mais une bonne
partie on s'est fourni auprès de
différents organismes qu'on peut trouver
en Île-de-France qui permettent
d'utiliser ou de réutiliser des
matériaux soit selon leur usage premier
soit on les réampleur de manière
différente
nous avons prévu d'activer notre cuisine
nomade durant les mois d'octobre et de
novembre et jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2023 et vous pouvez nous suivre sur les
réseaux à collectif
[Musique]